[Música]
[Aplausos]
mi palabra favorita es esperanza es el
nombre que le di a la empresa que
comencé hace casi una década para
desarrollar una nueva terapia contra el
cáncer de páncreas un proyecto que
venimos desarrollando por muchos años
acá en costa rica y que estamos cada vez
más cerca de poder generar una esperanza
para estos pacientes
es una palabra que esperamos y
necesitamos mucho justamente en estos
momentos porque la pandemia ha venido
para afectarnos a todos y no nos afecta
a todos por igual algunas personas están
sufriendo tremendamente y es un momento
en que la esperanza tiene que mezclarse
con la solidaridad
aquí tenemos una imagen de algo que no
hemos visto en algún tiempo que creen
ustedes qué pasaría si en medio de este
montón de gente de repente haremos caer
un oso
pues habría caos habría desesperación
gente corriendo por todos lados seguro
pasándole por encima a algunas personas
y seguramente habrían muchos heridos no
muy diferente a lo que pasaría si una
leona ataca a una manada de cebras en el
serengeti esto es algo que hace el virus
el virus nos divide el virus hace que
pensemos que tenemos que correr todos
para salvarnos y que queden atrás los
más débiles y los más vulnerables
pero yo no creo que seamos en este
aspecto como las cebras
qué tal si dejamos entrar ese mismo oso
en esa situación yo creo que la
respuesta sería mucho más diferente acá
vamos a tener movimientos de protección
de cuido acción inmediata para tomar
decisiones de salvar y proteger a
quienes queremos y lo único que está
diferente entre ese momento y el momento
anterior es que en esta imagen todos
tienen una misma idea del bien colectivo
de la importancia de actuar por los
demás de la importancia de reaccionar y
de tomar acciones que nos permitan
protegernos y cuidarnos
hay otra especie que actúa un poco
diferente que son las hormigas yo creo
que deberíamos parecernos tal vez un
poquito más a ellas en el hecho de que
podemos adaptarnos buscar soluciones en
conjunto por el bien global por el
bienestar de todos y que podamos así
avanzar porque este problema es un
problema que aunque nos afecta a todos
como individuos de forma diferente nos
afecta a todos como planeta tenemos que
actuar y cuidarnos todos unos a otros
para que podamos avanzar y tenemos que
también saber colaborar en esos momentos
eso es algo que se evidencia mucho con
el desarrollo de medicamentos hemos
desarrollado ya están en desarrollo más
de 700 diferentes medicamentos entre
terapias vacunas y antivirales que se
han desarrollado a través de
colaboraciones de grandes empresas
pequeñas empresas instituciones
académicas y científicos en todo el
planeta
aquí mismo en costa rica se están
desarrollando diferentes iniciativas
como por ejemplo la del clodomiro picado
de generar una nueva alternativa para
tratar de combatir el virus nosotros en
nuestra nuestra empresa también hemos
estado desarrollando una nueva y
potencial terapia nuestra tecnología se
basa en desarrollar pequeñas moléculas
que pueden regular la expresión de otras
moléculas que causan el cáncer metemos
estas moléculas al cuerpo utilizando
nanotecnología unas nanopartículas que
formamos de un nuevo material que pueden
proteger estas moléculas y nos permiten
inyectar las por vía sanguínea para que
corran por el cuerpo y lleguen a los
tumores llevando estas moléculas para
que actúen contra sus dianas
y lo que ha ocurrido de la pandemia
hemos decidido también aportar un poco
intentar aportar con nuestras
capacidades alguna resolución para la
pandemia
el virus utiliza sus especulas estos
picos en su superficie que son proteínas
especializadas para entrar en ciertas
células humanas éstas espículas se
sirven como una llave para abrir un ya
bean que es un receptor en ciertas
células del cuerpo estos estos
receptores se encuentran en muchos tipos
de células por eso es que el virus es
tan complicado nosotros hemos diseñado
moléculas capaces de atacar a la rn
viral y hemos modificado nuestras
nanopartículas en su superficie para
poder también entrar en las mismas
células que utilizan el virus nuestra
idea es tratar de generar un antiviral
que cuando entre en la misma célula que
el virus pueda destruir el aire en el
viral y de esa manera posiblemente
ayudar a los pacientes
este es este proceso que estamos
desarrollando se lleva a cabo gracias a
muchas colaboraciones no es algo
individual y creo que ninguno de los
otros grandes proyectos que se están
haciendo en nuestro país o en el mundo
se están haciendo solos tenemos que
entender que para que podamos salir
adelante tenemos que colaborar que todos
podemos poner de nuestra parte para
lograr salir adelante
creo que más que nunca se ha se ha visto
que la resolución de esta pandemia se
encuentra en realidad en las manos de
todas las personas todos tenemos la
responsabilidad de tomar acciones que
nos protejan de tomar acciones que
cuiden a los demás
les voy a dejar un ejemplo de otra
especie que creo que deberíamos emular
que son los árboles específicamente
estos árboles que se llaman los árboles
de aspen los árboles de aspen son todos
un solo organismo todos conectados por
una misma raíz que crece debajo de la
tierra y que nutre a todos los árboles
en momentos de dificultad los árboles
pueden compartir nutrientes y mantener
su raíz viva y fuerte para que puedan
volver a crecer de nuevo
rápida y fuertemente cuando las
condiciones lo permitan
al final todos somos solo uno
y todos a pesar de cómo nos afecte esta
pandemia de manera diferente de manera
individual con nuestras diferentes
formas de ver el mundo queremos lo mismo
[Aplausos]
[Música]